This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When basketball was invented as an indoor sport that could be played during long New England winters, the basket was literally a peach basket. And that basket was quickly replaced by a metal hoop with a rope and net. But it was still closed at the bottom, so every time a player scored a basket, the game had to stop and someone pulled out a ladder and retrieved the ball. You could also sometimes knock it out of the hammock with a long stick. But it took over a decade for someone to come up with the brilliant idea of cutting a hole in the bottom of a net.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当篮球作为一种可以在漫长的新英格兰冬季进行的室内运动被发明出来时，篮筐实际上就是一个桃子篮。那个篮筐很快就被一个带有绳子和网的金属圆环所取代。但它的底部仍然是封闭的，所以每当球员投进一球，比赛就必须暂停，有人得搬来梯子把球取出来。有时你也可以用长棍把球从网兜里捅出来。但过了十多年，才有人想出了在网底剪个洞这个绝妙的主意。
And it finally put an end to the practice of manually retrieving basketballs every time a goal was scored. That took a decade. Maybe it's a testament to how fun basketball is to play that the game can endure 10 years of such bad game design, regardless if someone not invented open-ended nets, basketball would sure suck the watch on TV. But it's a more subtle development that came decades later that made basketball the sports juggernaut that it is today. OK, I appreciate that not everyone listening is a sports fan. I'll learn from the radio program backstory, our reporter, Eric Manell.
这终于结束了每次得分都要手动取球的做法。这花了一十年。也许篮球运动能忍受长达10年的糟糕游戏设计，恰恰证明了这项运动本身有多么有趣。不管怎样，如果有人没有发明开放式的篮网，篮球在电视上肯定会让人看得索然无味。但正是几十年后出现的一个更微妙的发展，才使篮球成为了今天这样的体育巨头。好吧，我知道并不是每一位听众都是体育迷。我将从广播节目《背景故事》的记者埃里克·曼内尔那里了解更多。
But what's your feelings about basketball aside for just a few minutes and listen to the raw human emotion in this? Five seconds for go. Tied at 90. Trimovic, step back. Jump, prayer. Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah This in basketball is called a buzzer beer. The game-winning shot may just as time expires, it's exhilarating, it's heartbreaking, it's
但请暂时抛开你对篮球的看法，花几分钟听听这段录音中原始的人类情感：比赛还剩五秒。比分打平，90平。特里莫维奇，后撤步。跳投，祈祷吧。这就是篮球中的“压哨球”。这记制胜球在时间耗尽时投出，令人振奋，令人心碎，它是
a moment of pure anxiety that millions of people can share as one. And the fact that a 48-minute game of basketball can still be one in its final microseconds, thereby keeping you on the edge of your seat, chewing your fingernails to bits until the final buzzer, that my friends is what we call good design. Yeah, it is good design, but it's not the way basketball was originally designed. In fact, the drama of the game clock really only became relevant after the advent of another clock, the 24-second shot clock. This is the story of how this smaller, less visible clock.
一个数百万人在同一时刻共同感受的纯粹焦虑瞬间。事实上，一场48分钟的篮球比赛可以在最后几微秒内分出胜负，让你坐在座位边缘，紧张得咬指甲，直到终场哨响。朋友们，这就是我们所说的优秀设计。是的，这是优秀的设计，但这并不是篮球最初的设计方式。事实上，比赛时钟带来的戏剧性只有在另一个时钟——24秒进攻时钟出现后才变得重要。这就是这个更小、更不显眼的时钟的故事。
Shot clock winding down. Oh, it's a 24-second violation. Created a reaction to this clock. Outside for BAM. Let's go! Goddamn it! BAM with a triple-on glass! There was only a second on the shot clock!
进攻时间快到了。哦，24秒违例。创造了对这个时钟的反应。传给巴姆。投篮！该死！巴姆投进了一个打板三分！进攻时间只剩一秒了！
For the uninitiated, a shot clock is the smaller clock that you sometimes see counting down in the bottom corner of the TV screen. In the NBA, when a team gets the ball, they have 24 seconds to make a shot or it's a violation and they lose the ball. But this hasn't always been the case. In the early 1950s during Pro Basketball's infancy, there was no shot clock. Nothing forced a player to actually shoot the ball.
对于外行来说，进攻时钟就是你有时在电视屏幕右下角看到的倒计时小钟。在NBA，当一支球队获得球权时，他们有24秒的时间进行投篮，否则就是违例，他们将失去球权。但这并非一直如此。在20世纪50年代初职业篮球的起步阶段，并没有进攻时钟。没有什么能强迫球员真正去投篮。
And if a team was winning and they wanted to keep their lead, they could literally hold on the ball for 10 minutes. That means you could turn off the game and listen to this entire podcast and then go back to the game and not miss a thing. I mean the game stunk, it was boring, it was stupid. This is Dolph Shays. He's in the NBA Hall of Fame, a former player and coach whose career spanned two eras of basketball before the inception of the shot clock and after.
如果一支球队领先并想保持优势，他们真的可以把球控在手里10分钟。这意味着你可以关掉比赛，听完这整期播客，然后再回去看比赛，什么都不会错过。我的意思是，那时的比赛烂透了，无聊透顶，愚蠢至极。这是多尔夫·谢伊斯。他是NBA名人堂成员，曾担任球员和教练，他的职业生涯跨越了进攻时钟发明前后的两个篮球时代。
He says this problem of players running time off the inception of the shot clock and after. He says this problem of players running time off the clock by just dribbling the ball around can really be summed up in a 1950 game between the Fort Wayne pistons and the Minneapolis Lakers. It was a big game near the end of a season and the Lakers they had like a dynasty at that time and so the pistons who were ahead decided to have a slowdown meaning run time off the clock. Well, the game ended up 17 to 16 as the final score.
他说，球员通过运球来消耗时间的问题，可以用1950年韦恩堡活塞队和明尼阿波利斯湖人队之间的一场比赛来总结。那是赛季末的一场重要比赛，湖人队当时就像一个王朝，所以领先的活塞队决定采取“慢节奏”战术，也就是消耗比赛时间。结果，比赛最终以17比16结束。
The final score or something like that was in the teens. Actually, it was 19 to 18 go pistons. And of course, the crowd was booing. I mean, that it became a real forest. It was such a joke that in 1953 NBC decided to forego coverage of the NBA championship. They thought the game would be too boring. Finally, it became a crisis so basketball needed a rule change.
最终比分大概就是十几分。实际上是19比18，活塞队赢了。当然，观众们都在嘘。我的意思是，这成了一场真正的闹剧。这太荒谬了，以至于1953年NBC决定放弃转播NBA总决赛。他们认为比赛会太无聊。最终，这演变成了一场危机，所以篮球运动需要规则变更。
1954, Enter Danny Bison, owner of the Syracuse Nationals the team Dolph Shays played for by zone had crunch some numbers and he believed that some simple arithmetic could save basketball. And Danny by zone said look I have this formula. Why don't we try it out. By zone figured that the best games of basketball, the ideal games, had team scoring 80 or more points each. A score that Bison figured was high enough to retain the audience's interest. Right, so Bison started tracking how many shots the team needed to make to score a requisite
1954年，丹尼·比亚松登场，他是多尔夫·谢伊斯效力的锡拉丘兹民族队的老板。比亚松计算了一些数据，他相信简单的算术可以拯救篮球。丹尼·比亚松说，看，我有一个公式。我们为什么不试试呢？比亚松认为，最精彩的篮球比赛，即理想的比赛，每支球队得分都在80分或以上。比亚松认为这个分数足以保持观众的兴趣。没错，所以比亚松开始追踪球队需要投多少次篮才能达到要求的
80-something points. Each team averaged 60 shots per game and there's two teams that means 120 shots and the game was still 48 minutes long and 48 minutes equates to 2880 seconds so you divide the number of seconds in a game by the number of shots. 120 and you get 24 24 seconds per shot. And to hold a player to that standard, you need a 24 second shot clock by zone invited a bunch of League of Officials to Syracuse to watch a practice game using the shot clock. Our Mandolk Shays played in that game. Everybody felt the 24 seconds, let me it was a team's sense of time had become compressed.
80多分。每支球队平均每场比赛投篮60次，两支球队就是120次，而比赛时长仍为48分钟，48分钟等于2880秒，所以用比赛总秒数除以投篮次数120，得到24，即每次投篮24秒。为了让球员达到这个标准，你需要一个24秒的进攻时钟。比亚松邀请了一群联盟官员到锡拉丘兹观看一场使用进攻时钟的练习赛。我们的多尔夫·谢伊斯参加了那场比赛。每个人都感受到了24秒，球队的时间感被压缩了。
The old game didn't seem slow to the players, but with this new clock, everything felt rushed. And the owners loved it. They thought, wow, this is going to be great. Even in these practice games, there was a new sense of suspense. The owners felt it, and the players learned to love it, too. The clock became official in the 1954-55 season. Other changes in the pro game is limiting the offense of team to 24 seconds of possession with the basketball. If that offensive team does not try a shot in that space of time, it loses possession of the ball. Immediately, the scoring went up.
旧的比赛在球员看来并不慢，但有了这个新时钟，一切都感觉很匆忙。老板们很喜欢它。他们想，哇，这太棒了。即使在这些练习赛中，也有一种新的悬念感。老板们感受到了，球员们也学会了喜欢它。这个时钟在1954-55赛季正式启用。职业比赛的其他变化是将进攻球队的控球时间限制在24秒内。如果进攻球队在那个时间内没有尝试投篮，就会失去球权。得分立刻就上去了。
Shay is passing behind his back to Seymour who puts it away. The pistons are up against one of the longest sports jinks they've never beaten the Nats on the Syracuse court. This is audio from the 1955 NBA Finals, known then as basketball's World Series. It's the first year at the clock was instituted. Chase's team, the Syracuse Nationals, made it to the finals that season. His shot is off, but Chase gets the rebound. It's only 10 seconds remaining. The Shots Park did play an important part in our winning,
谢伊斯背后传球给西摩，西摩将球投进。活塞队面对的是体育界最长的魔咒之一，他们从未在锡拉丘兹的主场击败过民族队。这是1955年NBA总决赛的音频，当时被称为篮球的“世界大赛”。这是引入时钟的第一年。谢伊斯的球队，锡拉丘兹民族队，那个赛季打进了总决赛。他的投篮没进，但谢伊斯抢到了篮板。只剩下10秒了。进攻时钟在我们的胜利中发挥了重要作用，
because with the old rules, the piston probably would have held the ball for most of the second half. But because of the shot clock, we were able to claw away back and finally win it in a last couple of seconds. Roses, one hand, it clinches it. That's the story of basketball's World Series. Syracuse proves unbeatable for a fourth away on its home court. The next year, the NBA Finals were broadcast on television for the first time. Team scored almost 30 points more game those next few seasons.
因为按照旧规则，活塞队可能会在下半场大部分时间里控球。但因为有了进攻时钟，我们得以奋起直追，并在最后几秒钟赢得了比赛。罗塞斯，单手投篮，锁定胜局。这就是篮球“世界大赛”的故事。锡拉丘兹证明了在主场是不可战胜的。第二年，NBA总决赛首次在电视上转播。接下来的几个赛季，球队每场比赛得分几乎增加了30分。
And shortly after that, attendance jumped by 40%. So let me just list for you the reasons I actually like watching basketball. You can turn on a game of basketball in between commercial breaks of something else and still feel like satisfied that you saw something happen. It is the fastest paste, hands down. Like in a baseball game, you're not guaranteed to have that. And I love baseball, don't get me wrong, I love baseball. But there's a lot of sitting around in baseball.
此后不久，上座率跃升了40%。所以让我列举一下我喜欢看篮球的原因。你可以在其他节目的广告间隙打开一场篮球比赛，仍然会觉得满足，因为你看到了比赛进程。毫无疑问，它的节奏是最快的。比如在棒球比赛中，你不能保证会有这种情况。我喜欢棒球，别误会，我喜欢棒球。但在棒球比赛中，有很多时间是在坐着等待。
But if you go to a game of basketball, you're almost certain that something is going to be happening is so fast pace. I mean, that's wonderful, right? a lot of sitting around in baseball. But if you go to a game of basketball, you're almost certain that something is going to be happening is so fast pace. I mean, that's wonderful, right? And I love how athletic basketball players have become. I mean, the things you see LeBron James do are like out of this world. It's mind-blowing what he can do with a ball.
但如果你去看一场篮球比赛，你几乎可以肯定会有事情发生，节奏非常快。我的意思是，这太棒了，对吧？但在棒球比赛中，有很多时间是在坐着等待。但如果你去看一场篮球比赛，你几乎可以肯定会有事情发生，节奏非常快。我的意思是，这太棒了，对吧？而且我喜欢篮球运动员变得如此运动化。我的意思是，你看到勒布朗·詹姆斯做的事情简直不可思议。他能用球做出的动作令人叹为观止。
And even the worst guy on the court now is like a crazy athlete in ways that I never thought like human beings could be. The players have to be stronger and faster because they have this set period of time, they have 24 seconds to get the job done. But like before doing this story, I never would have thought that like the one thing that really made me love the game that made the game worth watching was some guy in Syracuse 60 years ago with a pen and paper and some long division.
即使是场上最差的球员，现在也是一个疯狂的运动员，其程度超出了我以往对人类能力的想象。球员们必须更强壮、更快，因为他们有固定的时间，他们有24秒来完成任务。但在做这个报道之前，我从来没想过，真正让我爱上这项运动、让比赛值得一看的原因，竟然是60年前在锡拉丘兹的一个人用纸笔和简单的除法算出来的。
He is the reason that this game is thrilling, this one little innovation. Not only did this game so much better, but made the players better themselves. Like it created better athletes. It pushed human potential to a totally different limit than ever would have been possible before. You know, it's all thanks to the shot clock. He scores!
他就是这项运动如此激动人心的原因，这一个小小的创新。它不仅让比赛变得更好，还让球员自身变得更强。它创造了更好的运动员。它将人类潜能推向了一个前所未有的极限。你知道，这一切都要归功于进攻时钟。他得分了！
Get him, he scores! He scores! And the buzzer! It'll have to be reviewed, or reviewed. For us, for God's sake. We're gonna take a look at it, But I'm going to Eric, there is yet one more thing that Abaskable does, a pretty good job with. I also really love half-time shows. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Eric Menel, based on his original story from the great, great radio show Backstory with the American History Guys. He had some help from Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute
抓住他，他得分了！他得分了！还有那个蜂鸣器！这必须经过回看，回看。看在上帝的份上。我们要看一看，但我会告诉埃里克，篮球还有一件事做得很好。我也非常喜欢中场表演。《99%隐形》本周由埃里克·曼内尔制作，基于他为伟大的广播节目《背景故事》所做的原创报道。他得到了萨姆·格林斯潘和我的帮助，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW和美国建筑师协会旧金山分会的一个项目。
of Architects in San Francisco. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram and Spotify, but to find out more about this story including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. For PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到并关注这个节目，我们所有人都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括精美的图片和链接，并收听《99%隐形》的所有剧集，你必须访问99pi.org。Radio Tapio。为PRX服务。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。